i'm on twitter right now i'm retweeting
a whole bunch of crazy stuff on luke we
are change about the insidious
love of power happening right now with
the establishment growling all over
joe biden we have cnn literally just
moments ago saying that
the side lights on the national mall's
reflecting pool
are like the extension of joe biden's
arms embracing america
cnn right now
saying that specifically david callan of
cnn and then of course
we have lauren wolfie who's at the new
york times the new york times made a
statement saying that they're going to
be critiquing this presidency just like
they did the other one that's their
public kind of word
and and then lauren wolfie says biden
landing at joint base andrew now
i have chills with a photo of of of
course the airplane coming in
this is just a creepy level yeah this is
so
here's what people need to understand
the government is power it's all
confidence
if if you have half the country not
believing in the power or the legitimacy
of
of the government then they won't have
that power to exert
and that's probably why they're doing
the screenings on these soldiers because
these soldiers are
look we heard from the oath keepers from
stewart rhodes he said that half the
country
will not view anything out of biden's
mouth as legitimate what happens when
soldiers are feeling that way well this
is why they're flexing this is why i
think they have
over 25 000 national guardsmen
showing them look at us we're the
authority we are strong we are powerful
i think this is why the mainstream media
is in overdrive
right now 24 7 non-stop saying biden's
the best he's beautiful he's glorious
he's going to save us he's going to do
everything for us as of course we all
know he's barely there
he represents the special interest
lobbyist more than
even barack obama wanted to be
represented in
the u.s government this is going to be
not just about
a new nor back to the new normal this is
a back towards pushing towards a state
that is truly uh at a very dangerous
point well moving forward from here
what's what's what's the old stereotype
of the of the bar
fight you got some loud boisterous
arrogant dude
pushing people around saying yeah i can
do whatever i want and there's some
quiet guy minding his own business just
sipping his drink
and then the guy comes up he's like come
on buddy what are you looking at and
he's like dude just leave me alone i
don't want to get into it
and it's a stereotype of the quiet guy
being the actual tough guy
he doesn't want to fight he wants to be
left alone let me have my drink you do
not want to fight you will regret it
and the guy talking all the smack is the
one who gets smacked down yeah so if
they're coming out flexing as hard as
possible
it seems like a facade yep like there's
they're actually
the actions they're taking scare me
because they have no confidence
the fact that they would vet our
soldiers the fact that chris cuomo and
cnn
would say we can't trust our military
i'm like jeez dude they're scared
issuing that letter you see that letter
that got released
it was uh um who was joint chiefs issued
a letter saying
biden won trump is not the president do
not support him
or else then we got all of the the
living
former secretaries of defense published
an opponent in the washington post
saying
anyone who supports trump to to keep him
in the presidency
will be prosecuted the fact they have to
put out these messages
send out 25 000 troops vet them they are
terrified that they have lost control
and they have lost confidence of enough
of this country
that it's going to create real
instability and they don't have the
power anymore yep
they have everything to prove and
nothing backing it and this is why it's
it's such a scary time because they
could be going for broke
and doing unspeakable things and just
like we mentioned uh before starting the
show
and this is kind of the theme that we've
been talking about in general
usually the people who call for combat
violence are usually the ones who have
never experienced it
you experienced it you know what it's
like uh
is there anything you want to say to
some of these kind of radicalized voices
about
you know what you see in a war zone and
the bigger kind of potential dangers
here
yeah well so you have the right the xbox
um player who
gets this false sense of reality like
they understand
combat and they understand tactics and
and they know all that with with with a
controller and
i think it gives sort of this uh false
bravado and maybe a
false sense of they actually think they
know what they're doing
but i mean i i doubt they've seen
charred bodies and people
blown in half from an rpg and someone
they know with a bullet in their head
those things change you those things
never leave you and
while in a war situation it's something
you have to do
it should not be anything you're looking
to do
because you have no idea you can put you
can turn that television off and
you can put that xbox controller down
uh but you witness and or take part in
that violence
you won't sleep right movies online
videos
they do not convey the true experience
of seeing
mangled bodies and one of the most
you i think a lot of people will not
understand it unless they ever
experience it they think they might
they think they oh i've seen videos
online i've seen nah
man i've seen videos online and i've
also seen people
a guy laying on the ground with his
lower lower legs were roast beef
as he was looking at his mangled meat
and his hands were just
not functioning and he's trying to move
it
the feeling you get when you see that
level of destruction of a human body is
something you will not experience in a
movie in a video game
well it is now clinically proven that
someone with
ptsd that your brain is actually rewired
yeah it happened it physically happens
to your brain i can't i can't even uh
there's it's crazy i want desperately
to convey the emotion i felt when i saw
a dude whose legs were gone
and he was looking at them trying to get
up and i'm like dude you can't
you can't get up yeah but people who who
like these these these lefties who go
and play larp
and they these antifa people throwing
fireworks and stuff
man they they they don't get it there
was a video out of portland and it
and it it was funny and it was sad but
it also made me angry
where a dude got an abrasion from like a
from a
you know where those phone expanding
foam rounds and so they put a tourniquet
on his leg
i remember they put a tourniquet on his
leg because he had an abrasion with some
it was some bleeding and they were he
was like
don't i don't want to lose my leg and
they're like we got to stop the bleeding
man i'm like
these people if it ever truly came to
the conflict they've been calling for
will cry so hard begging
for their xbox days back just to go back
and have that
that papa john's stuffed crust with the
garlic dipping sauce just one more time
they also don't understand what it's
like to not have resources and to eat
garbage and just man they've not they've
not seen real struggle they've not left
this country many of them
no that's that's a again i i always go
back to that
that perspective you know that
pinpointed perspective when you have
nothing else to rely on
outside of what you seen in a movie on
television or
you underst i mean you can understand to
a point i mean i i
i oddly enough feel some empathy just
because i understand
the cluelessness the cluelessness that
comes from a lack of perspective
and we also forget how privileged we are
how amazingly lucky we are
to live in a western world to have the
internet to have everything at our
fingertips
even though we're going through a very
tough economic turmoil
we still have it way better than the
majority of the world and and traveling
the world
and covering some conflict there there
were some events and things that i've
personally seen in my life that i just
blacked out
i i i know i've been there but i i don't
even want to go there i don't even want
to think about it
and this is why i've been always pushing
hey let's try to resolve this
calm down take a step back and and it
and it's very funny because you know the
voices your voice my voice a lot of
other independent media voices that are
trying to
bring reason to this insanity that are
trying to calm things down
those are usually the first ones that
get the nail they get the hammer
hit on them directly by big tech
censorship that is trying to silence
individuals from even
expressing these resolution voices you
know why
well the people who are who are invested
in the conflict
can't have people begging you know
everyone to stop fighting i don't agree
with that
i think the people calming them down are
fine no no what i'm saying is
there are people on the left who want to
fight and in order to justify their
fight they need the people to fight them
so if we come out and we say stop stop
doing this like brett weinstein's unity
party
they nuke it right if you challenge them
and tell them to stop they're gonna come
after you but if you're
truly trying to calm people down you're
not telling anyone to stop you're
creating something new
what do you mean you're making a better
place for everyone to go
telling people to stop focusing on the
conflict and the chaos
is different than telling them to start
focusing on growth
and that's what we do well telling
someone to stop is different than
telling someone to do it right so
einstein didn't tell people
to stop he said let's bring people
together and find where we agree and do
good things
i don't know i didn't i can't speak for
they banned they banned him they banned
him
when you look there's a tactic among
left-wing activists and
and i'm not saying this because i'm
trying to drag the left again it's
because the right is not organized in
this capacity when it comes to protests
they're not organized
that's why all these people from the
capital weren't wearing masks because
they had no idea what they were doing
and that's why they're going to go to
prison it's why when the proud boys got
into a fight with antifa in new york
city
antifa told the cops fu and ran away
even though they were supposedly the
victims
and the proud boys said we'll tell you
everything officer and guess who went to
prison the proud boys
the cops said we would have arrested
antifa we don't know who they are where
they went
because they have strategy they have
organization and they and they know
these tactics work
one of their tactics is to purposefully
get someone falsely arrested they want
a regular person walking down the street
to be thrown to the ground and beaten by
a cop so what they'll do is
they go to protests of normie you know
college student kids
they go they'll crouch down and they'll
chuck a rock at a cup then the cop will
grab
some 22 year old woman throw her to the
ground and she'll be freaking out why is
this happening i didn't do anything
wrong
then once she gets out because they bail
her out they supported her they'll say
don't you see how evil these cops are
you should join our group
shave the side of your head put on this
black hoodie we're the ones who saved
you
it is a common tactic they use get
people to be the victims
they want right-wing individuals at the
proud boys to show up and fight them
that's why i say it's a stupid thing to
do and they shouldn't do it they want it
so they can film it take it out of
context and then show regular people see
they're the bad guys join us we'll keep
you safe they
when the proud boys announce they're
gonna go march around with their with
their american flags and their gads and
flags what do we hear from the left
white supremacists are coming to target
minorities and racist attacks
an extreme version of
has not have nothing to do with reality
that's the propaganda technique
so they need the conflict so if we're
going to come out and say y'all you
don't want to fight it's bad
you don't understand how bad it's going
to get they're like no no stop them stop
them
they're actually trying to get people to
calm down that's bad for us well it's
how
listen to my point telling someone to
stop fighting is different
than doing something different that they
can focus on
instead of fighting and if you're
telling them to stop you will draw the
aggro
of the elite of the people with money
they don't want to hear you telling
people to stop they want to see you do
something new like write a song
or build a new technology that people
can use
i think ultimately anything that
threatens their you know
their the radicalization engine or their
tribe or their
their moral authority and justification
anything that threatens the flow
at risk the agenda of the narrative
they'll find a way to hit it i mean if
you look at
the youtube purge a lot of it first was
independent media
independent media was screaming about
child abusers radical islamists other
kind of crazy
people and individuals exploiting
whether it was puppies or little
children on the platform
they were still allowed to have a voice
the first crackdown the first crackdown
came on independent media
came on regular mom and pop small shops
of individuals saying
i want to be a youtuber i want to share
the news from a perspective
that's not from a corporate special
interest and
the first censorship was on dudes that
were screaming at george bush
saying that he was a child effort and a
goat effort
it was that that guy philip warren he
was the first
internet censored guy and he was
probably censored on
in the right because he was aggro as
f um you know that
is a very vague term you can you can be
agro independent media you can be
creative independent media i think aggro
stuff tends to get banned though it's
it's
it really is a bias against the right
and i i think it's hilarious
um that it's obvious if you take an
objective
view on what's going on look at parlor
just totally wiped out
it's gone it's obvious you know you look
at the
the channels that are allowed to be on
youtube they get promoted establishment
channels of course are protected
but then you look at left-wing channels
where they're talking about russia
and supporting these unhinged theories
and there's been no
there's there's been no reconciliation
there's been no justice there's been no
fairness in any of the policies put
forth by these platforms
it's like i was saying yesterday jack
dorsey is in a far left bubble he can't
see out of
to him all of these things are normal so
when he sees a regular working class
you know 45 year old guy tweet something
about learning the code he goes
an extremist delete not realizing
most americans have no idea what you're
talking about but they're getting nuked
these platforms are controlled by you
know
one of a large portion for the most part
of these ideological tribes
youtube seems to be this is surprising
it's bad there's a lot of problems with
youtube and censorship way better than
twitch for instance
twitch will ban you in two seconds for
giving a conservative opinion because
their their user base is too left
and then you have twitter which is very
left facebook which
is interesting this is interesting i i
used to upload my videos to facebook
and i stopped last week when they
restricted my page
for covering what happened at the
capitol that's it
and people were like i had people even
commenting saying all i did was say
here's what's happening here's a tweet
here's what's happening here's the
response
gone yep i have a telegram page with 5
000 subscribers and then i have a
facebook page with 600 000 subscribers
that was like that for a number of years
now
i get more web traffic and reach through
the 5 000
group on telegram than the 600 000 group
on facebook
that's why we're telling everybody to go
to timcast.com and become a member
because i fully expect look my facebook
page it's over
now i can still post to it but there's
no point the the
the posts are all restricted they've
stripped me from monetization which i
wasn't really getting in the first place
so i didn't care all that much when it
happened
but it shows you the cliffs are once
again eroding it's only a matter of time
before they come and say oh you you're
you're telling people to calm down
look we'll get to a point where they'll
say their fight is righteous
and and you know defending these people
means you're you're either with us or
against us and so by by defending people
by saying don't fight you're defending
them therefore you're banned we'll get
to that point
it'll happen and i don't know when but i
imagine it'll happen soon the first
thing they're trying to do is get rid of
all as many voices as possible
because they only want approved channels
youtube's wanted to be netflix for a
long time
they don't like the idea that anybody
can start a channel and just share
things they don't like the you in
youtube
but they want to maintain the user base
which they have so that's where we're
headed
so yes go to timcast.com become a member
if you want to help
protect us in the event that they they
nuke the the uh
the platform uh it's possible and we're
trying really hard to get like a core
dedicated user base to subscribe and
then we'll put up more and more
you you know member-only content and
stuff like that but i really i really do
hope things that you know things get
chilled out thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you